28 médicaments qui n'était plus
remboursés qu'à 40% le sont de nouveau à
70% il s'agit de certains médicaments
dits de confort ce qui porte une petite
vignette bleue leur définition n'est pas
très approprié puisqu'elle couvre à la
fois des produits indispensables au
traitement de certaines maladies graves
et d'autres beaucoup moins important une
mesure qui satisfait les usagers mais
pas les professionnels y compris les
pharmaciens alors jean daniel flaysakier
ce que cette notion de confort
rationalise un peu les dépenses
médicales ce qu'est ce qu'il faut dire
didier sait que dans ces médicaments
dans les médicaments qu'ils viennent de
nouveau des eaux nouveau pardon d'être
repris 70 % point de vue remboursement
il n'y avait aucun médicament majeurs
c'est-à-dire irremplaçable en revanche
la notion de confort est bien difficile
à estimer est-ce qu'on peut mettre sur
un même pied la sensation nauséeuse du
passager d'un voilier de croisière et
les vomissements d'une personnes
traitées par chimiothérapie dans le
cadre du traitement d'un cancer sûrement
pas et pourtant l'un et l'autre vont
avoir recours aux mêmes médicaments
alors est-ce qu'on doit pénaliser le
second en voulant responsabiliser le
premier cela semble très difficile il
n'empêche qu'à plus ou moins long terme
le remboursement des médicaments au prix
fort va devoir cesser
en effet l'industrie pharmaceutique
réclama réajustement tarifaire est donc
inévitable de voir le prix des
médicaments montée mais le remboursement
être plafonnés d'une façon d'une autre
parce que déficit de la sécurité sociale
on toujours l'esprit des ministres quels
que soient les gouvernements
merci jean réal pour ces précisions
[Musique]